chaque seconde qui passe
raccourci notre futur newton c'est pas à
moi le pin's sait jamais s'il existait
un endroit là regarde ça je te dis tu
trouves pas que ça visait un endroit
secret pour rien soit impossible
quand j'ai touché spis j'ai vu un
endroit incroyable tu as vu un endroit
secret où les meilleurs et les plus
brillants d'entre nous se sont réunis
pour changer le monde
nous cherchions quelqu'un comme toi
depuis très longtemps
pourquoi qu'est ce qui s'est passé
là-bas une catastrophe
une envolée qui sont prêtes à l'emploi
il n'y a qu'un seul accès
on arrive alors plus loin
pourquoi vous m'avez choisie moi il
pense que tu peux réparer le monde
voir le monde de demain
tout y est accroche toi